when the eagles play the seahawks on
monday night to cap week 12 will carson
wentz b bench coach doug peterson went
on a roughly three minute soliloquy
today defending his quarterback then he
was asked questions whether or not his
quarterback was still the starter here's
some of what went down
oh
you're not making that move right dog to
a different quarterback
not today on wednesday no
okay possibly for for monday
um i'm focused right now on getting
better today
i mean
i i don't know i mean
i would say no no
no
carson just started for monday
yes
i think that that was a little effort by
doug peterson to engage in some verbal
sword play it almost reminded me of the
way that jim harbaugh used to be with
the 49ers when he felt like every press
conference was a competition and his
demeanor suggested that he was typing
out the words that he was thinking about
saying on an invisible screen in front
of his eyes and reading them and making
sure that they were okay before he said
them and i think peterson just kind of
tripped over himself and walked into
this impression that maybe carson wentz
will be in trouble come monday night i'm
still convinced
they're sticking with carson wentz
because they're stuck with carson wentz
and i saw somebody making the argument
today well at some point you just have
to say hey it's sunken costs and rip off
the band-aid and he's hey you know we
got to pay him but no no he's going to
take up a huge percentage of your salary
cap next year you can't have a guy
sitting on the bench to whom you're
paying 25 million dollars in a year when
the cap is 175 million you have to try
to keep making chicken salad no matter
how much chicken stuff is otherwise
getting all over your shoes you have to
keep trying you have no alternative
until after next season that's the deal
they did when they signed into that huge
long-term contract
i am curious mike how much of this is
the fact that they don't really have any
weapons and the two biggest weapons they
have are their tight ends and we know
that doug peterson likes to play a lot
of 12th personnel and they zach hurts
has played only six games and dallas
goddard has played only six games and
they weren't the same six games but when
travis fulgam all due respect to travis
fulton when he's your leading receiver
your favorite receiver i think you've
got problems at the receiver position i
mean there's a reason that this guy was
caught cut
multiple times and ended up on the
eagles and he's played great for the
eagles but he's not a number one
receiver and you know jalen rhaegar was
hurt their number one draft pick but i
just wonder how much of it mike is that
is not having the weapons not having
help they've had all those injuries in
the offensive line how much is on carson
wentz and how much is on the rest of the
team
yeah well we saw it last year though
when it was carson wentz
and a band of no names and carson wentz
somehow willed that team to the playoffs
so we were spoiled by that so we're
thinking hey oh you don't have weapons
you did it last year why can't you do it
this year and i think that's the
lingering problem i continue to believe
he's pressing he's trying to do too much
he's trying to justify trading up to
draft him picking him over nick foles
and paying him that big contract all at
once in one play in one moment and then
everybody will quit criticizing him and
i just feel like there's that urgency to
overdo it and i think that's one of the
problems and they've got to get it
figured out everybody's going to be on
the hot seat in philadelphia going into
the 2021 season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports